[Musik]
du bist für unsicherheit und
abgesprochen und würdiger die heute vom
kleinen baggers lakers wieder auch nennt
bekommen bei einem neuen video
habt ihr bock auch mini tour bei
leichter so kommt das video fast schon
30.000 weg deswegen habe ich mir da
wenig als ein baum auf der tour und bei
uns halt nur gesagt es steht jetzt
wirklich packt da nicht noch nicht alle
noch keine küche aber gut wegkommen
glocken werden woraus aber sozusagen ein
paar sachen werden einfach verändern
aber grobkonzept steht und ich bin
länger zu spielen das ist megageil und
deswegen will ich auch gar nicht lange
dauern und viel sagen ich bin sehr
gespannt schauen
ich hoffe er findet die wohnung auch
ganz schön an sichtung für uns weisen
voll wir haben jetzt eine luxuswohnung
audioline rechte für mich und alle leute
kommt damit denn die küche
okay bin gut aus dort gar kein problem
wir wissen
und da wir einen hut
und wir haben ja auch ein luft und her
wieder heranbringen elefantenkuh
leiterplatte erhältlich in 0,2 sekunden
und kann den ball klar halte man nur
kommen wenn die chemikalien in der
[Musik]
östlichen morgen mit gerüchten formal
korrekte nur hochwertig kann man sagen
wieder sich autor und eine lehrstelle
bleiben ist nichts davon wenn du den
beiden sagen gar nicht erst mal eine
gute oder hat einfach weiter
dafür treten
von mir drin nicht weinen lassen die
schulen um eine schule dran meine tour
gedeihen so wir gehen entspannt ich
bestimmen also ja eine lernende martin
morgen wenn ich aus dem haus gehe alle
meine cd mein auto update auf belastung
glaubt melzer in meinen versorger
deswegen lohnt sich auf jeden fall weiß
nennt mich trennen oder wenn dort wurden
hierbei war also ich muss mal abwarten
wann man verlegt das menschenrecht oben
ist echt richtig nein
darauf könnt ihr euch vielleicht meinen
alten freund natürlich auch ein
praktikum erhalten wir nicht die
schlacht ist meine partner anzulocken
die meisten anlagen irgendwann meinen
gästen anbieten und meinen körper
manchmal veraltet oder so dann hilft dir
noch andere später ein beispiel dafür
das habe ich jetzt in meinem achten
geburtstag bekommen wo ein paar coole
bilder darauf den von mir als kind oder
mit meinen freunden meiner familie oder
sonntag montiert noch empfiehlt das
kennt auch wieder der früher eher im
hintergrund aber immer gelder erst
meinen extreme bürgerinnen und weiter
bis jetzt gar nicht genau klar logisch
ein bisschen viel applaus und ein
schwarzes brett und mit darum dass
gleich aufstecken auf den verwender so
unter wasser
[Musik]
das ist ein tropfen besteht hier nur
drin weil ich hab einfach noch keinen
appell jetzt will ich sagen eine
deutsche wenn ihr ein anschlag wurden
zwei weitere sorgen können
nach oben und oben ist echt richtig geil
leute seite bereit 38 leute damit wieder
4 bisschen was zeigen können brauchen
wir mal kurz um alte leute kurzen
parcours heute gestellt ist das ganze
ein bisschen heller
ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach mal
ganz locker idee hier in meiner ecke an
wo ich auch eigentlich machen einen
videochat in zukunft regeln und vereine
die hier einmal ganz normalen mai
empfangen möchte einfach mal so hier nur
shooter kommen jordan zeigt der helm
einem eine million play button der
100.000 wenn ich direkt eine million
hauptstädte meine ersten autogrammkarten
ich mal schlappe erheblich einfach noch
blockbuster und ein paar andere sachen
[Musik]
hier haben wir also auf jeden fall
einfachsten sachen hängen
ich finde ich bin ziemlich zufrieden
aber gleich sagen gegenüber weiter zu
meiner lieblingsstädte und zwar bitte
zwei verschiedene läuft ketten
aufgehangen
die eine leuchtend pink und die anderen
dass kameras in grün und orange oder
blau und blau oder einfach aus
automat mit meinen gefühlen wenn
jemandem wie juristen ab gegangen
vielleicht auch manchmal wie das einfach
im ganz dunkel auf der kamera
liebe leute geht nicht jetzt gibt ja
einfach außen wohl ist mit seiner
pistole und ex klub von der ganzen kommt
man kann für die ganze stadt darunter
kuchen kann man die reifen ist leute
einfach rot was die nachbarn köln beim 1
darum sieht man eine skyline
wolkenkratzer der wirklich extrem hoch
und genau unter unserer wohnung steht
immer ein vorstellen
auf dem tisch liege höher mich natürlich
und das ist ihr alltag machen wir einen
leichten können dabei auch leichtes
spiel
das problem habe ich glaube ich noch in
kandidat bin frei und wir haben nur
einen schlechten vier von frenzel
spielen und ja ich noch hin gekauft doch
keinen zweiten reihe stark der lkw
fahrer und ein zuschauer schick mir doch
mal bitte einfach bei den vier
elektrische lange mit geschützten arten
von apple aber zufrieden
hier habe ich auch schon länger an zügen
fuhren
alter
[Musik]
mit ihr sollte mich mein bruder für mich
ein berg hatte blackpool einrichtet auf
jeden fall für die leute entwickeln wir
unser auto hand die habe ich mir mal
geklaut weil sie wahrscheinlich nicht
eingesteckt ist ein 2 alexander macbook
pro video guckt man schenkt und die
einzel guckt von hey was geht
hier wollte ich immer so besteht im
nachhinein bringt dabei um eine pepsi
und ansonsten das wird noch nach
auf jeden fall schön immer ein schöner
aus schöner erholte jahren eine
dachwohnung und da vielleicht ein
kleiner kleiner und ewz unterwerk
kommentieren wir oben drauf
gemütlichkeit mal hunger hat und in dem
kühlschrank sind auch noch ein paar mehr
gesunde lebensmittel wie zum beispiel
wird sagen können kommentiert diese
findet findet bereits 17.000 und
forschung betrieben überwiegend am
sonntag wieder
ich weiß davon ich hoffe euch gibt ein
gut und das kind nur neues video ein
großer kämpfer und setzte im juni kenia
da kommt auch einfach coole sachen rein